لقد حصلت على وجه واحد من buswell عندما أقوم بتحميل
مقطع فيديو على YouTube ، من المحتمل أن أجني
ما يكفي من المال لشراء قهوة باهظة الثمن
في Starbucks ، لذا بالنسبة لي شخصيًا
كنوع من منشئ المحتوى ،
ألقي خطابات تحفيزية وهذا هو
الدخل الأساسي لأنك في الحياة تحصل على
مثل  العديد من الضربات التي تريدها سيصدر كتابي التالي
في كانون الثاني (يناير) ، لقد كتبت كتباً
أقوم برعاية بعض المشاركات التي قمت برعايتها
بقدر ما تكون وظيفتي من الناحية المالية نوعًا من
نظام بيئي لتدفقات الإيرادات المختلفة
شكرًا لك على رعاية
هذا  رحلة كما قلت إذا كنت لا
تبيع البضائع ، فأنت تترك المال
على الطاولة في نهاية اليوم الذي أبيع
فيه بطاقات تنبيه التوحد التي تشبه هذه
البطاقات الصغيرة التي تبدو مثل هذا
الشخص المصاب بالتوحد كرقم طوارئ
على ظهر  هذا هو
المنتج الأكثر مبيعًا على موقعي وأشياء من
هذا القبيل أعتقد أن valances تمتلك الحياة في
مقابل القليل من تحقيق
الدخل.فيديو اليوم برعاية بسيطة
وهناك صفقات مع العلامات التجارية والآن بدلاً من
الحصول على إعلان عشوائي  أعلن المعلن على
الفيديو الخاص بك ، فأنت بدلاً من ذلك تعقد اتفاقًا
مع علامة تجارية معينة أو معلن ، هل
تريد أن تخجل من معاملة النساء المتحولات
بأسرار صغيرة قذرة ، فإن جميع
الأموال تقريبًا على magneto تأتي من تمويل المعجبين ،
لذا فإن العميل يشبه Kickstarter باستثناء
الدفع المتكرر حتى يدفع الناس لي
شهرًا تمامًا مثل خدمة الاشتراك
هو كيف يمكنك التفكير في الأمر بالنسبة إلى المعجبين مثل
مقاطع الفيديو الخاصة بي بما يكفي ، فهم مستعدون للدفع لي
لجعلهم على الرغم من أنهم
متاحون مجانًا وهو نوع
مذهل تخيل أن هذه هي
الأرض وأعتقد  إنها بنية حوافز أفضل
بكثير من أرباح الإعلانات ، لأنه إذا
كنت تجني الأموال من الإعلانات ، فأنت تعلم أن
إستراتيجية عملك على أي
حال ستضع أكبر قدر
ممكن من المحتوى وتحصل على أكبر عدد ممكن من النقرات
ولا داعي للقلق
حول هذا الأمر أكثر من اللازم لتكلفته ، في حين أن
ما لدي دافع لفعله هو إنشاء
محتوى جيد بما فيه الكفاية بحيث
يرغب الناس في دفعه مقابل ذلك